today we have a special episode I
brought in to my good friends Kelly
Nishimoto from LA as well as Antonio
Centeno from Wisconsin complete
different places and I brought him in
because you know I've been struggling
with something and publicly I'm going to
admit to this and kind of it's kind of
strange for me to admit to this my good
friend Paula scarce ago we've been
trying to get Paul to go on a date and
clothes and get them to be more
fashionable and and I have to find some
miracle workers so I you know rumor on
the street is Kelly makes miracles
happens and obviously Antonia makes
miracles happen so part one we have will
you come and join here with us Paul here
a a very handsome mid-30s
very smart loves philosophy loves movies
we're trying to see if we can we can
dress him up in a way where he can go on
a date and he can close and potentially
we don't have to wait till I'm 80 years
old to go to his wedding one day because
he says he doesn't want to have a family
when they will see if that's going to
take place or not so with that being
said before we get into you in your
early 20s you were in your early twenty
sixteen years ago so it's a whole
different story
so look Kelly yes we've known each other
not for I don't know eight years
something like that eight years and
you've been on TV you had your own show
something borrowed something new you got
a clothing line cute booty which is a
cult-like type of a following you have
going on tell us a little bit about
yourself I started my career um when I
was 13 I got a sewing machine and I just
started sewing away Patrick and you know
that led me to starting my own line in
Miami where I threw my own fashion shows
I'm completely self-taught and then I
moved to LA about 16 years ago started a
runway collection which then led into
the lounge collection which led into TV
and it's blitz blown up so I'm blessed
and Here I am it's something about your
clothing then I felt immature it's just
incredible the way these cute booty
pants feel like everybody who wears it
if you have a ladies if you haven't had
it you got to go try it on - booty
lounge calm you should go try it okay
I'm Tony on this side great story
former Marine officer and we've talked
about that before quite a lot
extensively
the lack of perfection with the marine
folks but he was an officer I was
enlisted in the US Army and he now has
seven hundred and fifteen thousand
subscribers on YouTube the number one
guy for men's style and the way he
teaches I have to say you got to be the
number one educator and the way you
teach styles so tell us a little about
your background well as you mentioned
I'm a former Marine I'm a father I'm a
husband I live in a small town in
Wisconsin and I use the science of style
to make fashion relevant to men because
I most guys are kind of confused by what
maybe don't see it as important so I
really try to hit an emotional chord
show guys how they can use in style to
get what they want out of life so I use
my biology background and I talked about
how biology background biology
background so I take my button mitosis
meiosis type of thing or well a little
bit about evolutionary biology I know
how we compete for mates how actually
when you dress a certain way you can
invoke certain feelings and trust of
competence when a guy understands that
that there's science that there is
actually a lot of history behind this
all of a sudden he feels more confident
when he won't goes to wear a flower in
his lapel he realizes oh there were
soldiers in World War one they did this
and so I can have the confidence I'm
next not doesn't make me less of a man
to wear a flower it actually is
something it's very masculine so you
guys couldn't be you know more polar
opposites than you know you got the pink
hair you don't you know you're very you
know put together from the ladies
perspective from a man's perspective so
we're really curious to know do you
really want to take up this challenge of
making a miracle happen today with Paul
you confident you can pull this off oh
yeah we first of all he's tall which is
always easier to dress a tall person am
i right there's less alterations that
have to take place so that's number one
that's great look at him he's cute he's
got the dimples he works for you so
obviously he's doing something right yes
and those are the nipples I just noticed
I think it's an easy case yeah I'm
looking at his overall build this is
gonna be easy I mean what we're trying
to accomplish sounds like you're taking
us to a great store yeah you know this
is this is gonna be easy easy I think
the thing that is just sticking with me
though I mean you've been wearing her
pants did she mention I love her pants
is that secretly I'm glad you saw us
because we were working out this morning
again he had a spandex on and I had this
I had his that you were brave for window
spandex till midnight I haven't seen a
Marine officer pull it off but he pulled
it off
masculine walking around hitting the
weight we were well we were doing yoga
and we were sweating right was that not
fascinating at this yoga place there's a
side of Antonio you guys do not know
about but I promise you I'm gonna
explore that side on value taming so it
sounds like you guys are both ready we
want to thank also sacks but because
we're going to do this project at Saks
5th off 5th in Dallas on Park Lane which
the entire team we're looking forward to
coming out and see what we can pull off
here together so with that being said
how about we we get to work and we start
seeing what we're gonna do let's do it
all right let's go through and tell you
how about you go first with Paul not
gonna lie - I have not slept
you've lost sleep over I was a purple
halogen guys his deliver attainment our
followers are messaging about all ready
to shop heck yes okay so let's talk
really quick I want to know a little bit
about your personal style what you what
you're looking for like how you want to
come across to your date pretty open
overall as long as it fits good and
feels good you know I'm pretty pretty
easy when it comes to that okay
and one last question do you when you
get dressed you dress for women or you
dress for men okay just a question
it's part of the process all part of the
process ultimately I do a dress for both
I mean I don't want to not please one
side like I feel it shouldn't be so
harsh so I don't know I feel like if you
dressed nice for women most guys would
be like yeah that's nice let's go
shopping tonight moving on so the goal
for Paul is I want to get him three
complete outfits that represent kind of
three parts of what we talked about what
he wants to look like what he wants to
feel like an ideal style and I want them
to be three completely different I want
them to represent him but I also want
them to step outside the box just a
little bit of an ahjussi was a
nice-looking guy he's in his prime but I
want him to be classic with a little bit
of a modern edge
let's face it women love a little
swagger so you want him to look as if he
is a well-put-together entrepreneur
manly man bold a little bit of an edge
so let's find your size come around this
way and let's go find your size I like
the darker denims for you oh I see you 3
8 what is this it's not and it's a
lighter wash but no one honest even
possible let me 632 me chance it's
stretchy to it just says 36 I'm gonna
feel length straight narrow brixon okay
let's try it
I mean what it's not gonna hurt oh I see
38 size 13 the largest size and the
store ladies
when I'm shopping for myself I literally
check out I'm in dreamland and I'm
having the best time in my life but
shopping for a man is a lot different
especially when it's not your man so
first of all that's solid purple with
the blue the pants are perfect not too
tight not too loose it's just the
perfect Turner I give us a good turnout
they can hand out of your pocket for
minutes concerning what do you think
about force for change I like a lot
we're going we don't know yet we have
the girl yet look at all I'm good okay
thank you
good I love love love this shirt yeah
and he knows geo theory the brand theory
great brands it's been around for years
and years it's been around for like 20
years
yeah so I you're the Guru
mom I am NOT the Guru and you're not the
schmuck okay maybe I am the Guru but
you're definitely not this love 359 29
that is a lot it's almost 150 dollars
under budget that's because I'm the head
you know what I'm trying to say that's
impressive you got in me listen I
respect you
giggle buddy
hell are you ready I'm ready
apparently you're ready to present the
product power to the rest yeah I'm proud
of my work actually the first man I've
ever styled really officially you know
you style your your man man yeah my man
man um be honest the first person I was
hired to style I think it did a great
job
I basically dressed him as like I were
going on a date with him what I would
like to see him walk into the restaurant
or pick me up in are you ready to
present the product I'm ready to present
the product my only problem
Pat is we have you know we have some
great outfit choices I'm really worried
about the car can he borrow your car to
pick up the date or I mean that could
Ducks could be a dual mechanism you can
deal great would all the dents I did car
like I'm worried if I give the car comes
back with three dents in it to work on I
think he should just over to the date I
then it's safer yes yeah I think we
should just get nice Oh bro that should
be a better idea I don't know if I want
to risk the car with you Paulie
I came under budget so I think we can
use the additional 150 for your uber
that's right yeah that's right we can do
that we can do that so you Paul you want
to show us what you got come on here
Paul voila so I work off of color and
vibrations not to sound like the kooky
lady with pink hair yes but I love
colors and mixed textures and patterns I
wanted to keep it really simple I don't
like it I'm in over dress and we have to
be a little more realistic because it's
a date and the we're in Dallas or the
weather's still a little warmer so you
can get away with a sweater at nighttime
I don't want to over layer him he is a
bigger guy ah you think guys do that a
lot like way too much layering uh select
a typical animal for men it's a typical
TV trick to over layer because it looks
good it looks guy on camera it looks you
know it's a polished look it's what the
magazine's are showing but you know
realistically when you go to restaurant
you're not going to wear five layers
you're gonna be a man you're big you're
gonna be hot is crap you're gonna start
taking off these layers you'll be
itching your to be uncomfortable you've
got the scarf with the thing but the
thing with the tank
with shirt with the over there with a
button-up with the Venice with us too
much um Paul's a simple man I wanted to
keep him within the realms of what he
would be comfortable it's no simile
dressed you had a complex mind your son
messy car and it's in a simple dresser
uh can we make sure no one ever sees the
car yeah really like off-limits ladies
you're not gonna see his car
can we put a b-roll footage of his car
and no oh my god there's no beer oh god
okay noises look it's a functional car
it gets me a point you'd be on the drive
okay I really had a hard time deciding
between this outfit and then the outfit
with the leopard just seppies and no D's
you like that one a lot yeah II like
that one a lot I think that one was
pretty genius but I'm what I like the
fact I like the fact that you don't let
him close you on wanting to keep that
outfit because he wanted that to be the
outfit to present it I mean I feel like
you wanted him to choose that outfit so
you could borrow the shoes the shoes
work on I would definitely support those
shoes all day long you would stay here
okay can we do you mind if we show the
picture with the giuseppe's of Paulo
completely it's a great Mario are you
sure show up Olli would adjust this is
what Paulie looked like with the
giuseppe's so Kelly I got a question for
you I got a question for you so first of
all Paul do you feel good right now
there's there's nothing like great I
noticed the way you were walking today
we had to keep you away from the other
side of the headquarters for tea with
the girls because it was like too much
confidence he walked in with an entirely
different attitude I saw them you know
he's a little taller you you didn't
slouch couple inches the colors look
really good on you I love the color
combo we're still utilizing color but
without going overboard um you are a
manly man you've got the black hair
you've got the really nice skin tones
I think these jewel tones complement
that without being too much I gotta look
at you and think oh wow he's wearing way
too much color it just fits you the
pants are nice Paul's got a great butt
by the way ladies very nice derriere Oh
mommy and daddy whatever you did Chris
so it's important to find a nice fitting
pair of pants that wasn't too loose it
wasn't too tight on his thighs we kind
of men have that problem a lot of times
and I really wanted to bring in a more
fun aspect in a casual aspect with the
Chuck Taylors and I hope you warriors
you did wear your socks see you go po
can't be too serious when your drift
fashion is not brain science we're not
you know we're not performing any
medical miracles here so you have to
have a little bit of fun in with your
outfit I got a question for you I got a
question for you do you think you dress
in him from the point of view of a woman
is different than a man dressing him
from the point of view of a man a dress
today
so what is the difference in your
opinion the difference in my opinion is
well I'm dressing him the way I would
want to see my date walk in you know and
it's also two different things if I were
dressing him for a magazine shoot or for
say a red-carpet event or we're
attending some type of event not a gala
obviously that would be a suit I would I
would have taken a different approach
but because it's a first date you want
to present yourself as serious but also
fun colorful but also grounded you know
clothes say a lot about a man and you
want to keep it polished but you don't
want to overdo it you want to have some
type of you want to feel you want your
date to feel relaxed so if you're
overdressed or you're over buttoned up
or over suited I feel like although it's
a great look for business or some
occasions for a first date you want to
really be inviting sounds good well we
like it Holly oh why don't you now go
with our frontier Antonio and see if he
can make a miracle happen with you in a
complete different out I like this one
actually I know what he has prepared for
the rest of us I'm excited so excellent
very cool
we are going to be taking Paul's level
of style up an entire notch so I've had
this challenge presenting me from the
guys over at Value tainment and they
want me to work with Paul to basically
look at what he's bringing to the table
and help him figure out how to set the
best first impression now this is
ideally for a date this is could be
something he's just gonna meet friends
at a bar but this isn't gonna be
something I'm not looking to put
together a suit more casual wear
something that he can send the signal
he's got style he knows he wants to send
the right signal but at the same time we
got to stay within a $500 budget so
you're ready to make it happen let's go
to it
Oh Tanya good to see you again good to
see you all right man you all ready to
make this happen
let's do it all right what we're going
to focus in on really it's going to be
the shirt it's going to be the pants but
it's the shoes that we're going to start
for 100 we're going to build this entire
outfit around the shoes all right so
when we're starting off with shoes I
mean this is one of the foundation of a
man's wardrobe this is footwear normally
I would say you want to spend most your
money on a suit on a suit jacket but
that's going to be for interviews that's
going to be for when you're building
your base wardrobe at this point you're
looking for first impressions you're
going out on a date most men aren't
going to be wearing a suit out on the
first date we also are in Dallas Texas
so we got to pay attention to the
weather
it's hot it's sometimes casual and gets
a little bit humid here but above all
it's hot and so like I said we're going
to go back and choose a shirt but we
want to choose this is something that
you can wear shoes with a lot of
character but we want to make sure we
get the right level of formality I'm
going to go over what I can see with
Paul is we've got a good well-built
chest his shoulders right here he's got
square shoulders just slightly not too
bad I think we measured about 20 inches
across in the shoulder area go ahead and
put your arms down he's got a little bit
longer arms so what I'm guessing right
here is that you have trouble fitting
clothing right in this area and that's
going to be a trouble a hot spot so
whenever we're looking for shirts
anything we want to make sure it fits in
this area we may find something that we
like the look we like the color it's
perfect except it doesn't fit and that
is as much as we like it we can't buy it
so Paul what you're going to want to
look for is identify not just what you
like in colors but also the brands that
fit you well here because you're going
to want to stick and become brand loyal
because if a brand fits you here it's
going to be something you can go online
and purchase other things from right
this is I think a great outfit for a lot
of guys definitely step I know how do
you feel about this good I don't know
about this this is gonna be interesting
let's go try something else did Bali
alright yeah yeah let's check out
morning said we do the whole bit
Caterpie everything is interchangeable
tenses I guess the question I would have
for you you feel better yourself the
confidence by knowing that what you
learn as a match and you look good yeah
absolutely absolutely I think you know
it's obviously is always nice to hear
your compliments everybody likes that
but also I think just understanding some
of the logic sometimes sometimes you
know you can get crazy with your mind
and they just don't know because you
don't have experience but hearing other
people give advice and then kind of
tailor it to you and understanding the
principles I think it's critical so
thank you everyone for shopping with
Saks office in Dallas okay so I'm not
sure if you can top that because the way
Paul came in here you kind of control
the room but you know when he walked in
with this man this is this is some nice
stuff here so why don't you tell us what
you were thinking when you got this
outfit for Paul so the first thing I do
I look at a man is I look at okay how is
he built and what can I do with his
existing body this is something most men
can't change overnight so I looked at
his shoulders I looked at his chest
build I'm like this is his strength this
is what we've got to focus in emphasize
he's got height we talked about that at
the beginning sure but you know be able
to build up those shoulders build up
that chest that's always going to make a
man look more masculine look more strong
so focus in on his strengths so so that
was our emphasis with the outfit so what
you're saying is you know for the ladies
out there he's well-built
what you're saying just like again I
mean definitely he is a man if you want
to pass on good genetic traits to your
children look at this guy all right
solid endorsement from Antonius you got
to endorsement so far so so why don't
you once you show us the product come on
in Paul woo
lookie lookie Paulie so the jacket I
want to say that the jacket I think most
men they say maybe I'm not a jack
we're kind of guy well do they really
they thought about it what it does for
builds up the shoulders builds up the
chest actually makes the hands look
stronger bigger more masculine if you go
back to evolutionary biology I mean it
was something that mates were chosen
based off the size and the strength of
the answer in every one which human by a
lotion about ology exactly the color
here mimics also was here focuses us on
the face he's got a good brow line good
uh you know when I look at his jaw
everything here is emphasized with the
bit of color we've got the v-shape that
is being built now the pants right here
I have to admit I'm not necessarily a
slim you know kind of Pat guy but he
loved him he gravitated towards him he
wears him with confidence so in this
particular case and the color called
inaudible yeah he's this guy right here
he owns this look so me I probably
wouldn't I would have gone with
something a little bit loose but for him
it worked and we were able you could
interchange any of this so with
everything I choose I always think an
interchangeable wardrobe I want a guy to
be able to buy investment pieces so he
could bring in regular blue jeans a dark
denim and indigo he could drop the
jacket and all of a sudden he would
still have a good look if it got a
little bit hot now the shoes we want the
very neutral gray something that's going
to be fun casual a bit of texture on
them we looked at some other ones out
there there was a blue pair that you
loved which actually bought me ended up
buying it on his own time and what he
has like those shoes yeah but I think
that we still got some of the texture
right here the other ones were suede
this right here with a little bit of you
know right in there but overall I feel
that this is a look and he'll be able to
pull off if he wants to dress it down he
could even wear a black or a navy blue
type of jacket with this and dress it up
even a little bit higher so how do you
feel Paul I feel excellent I feel
excellent
I definitely love trying out the
different things and just I love hearing
both different sides of the coin
different different ways to approach it
but very very important what would you
say you'll learn from Kelly that you
didn't know what you love from him that
you didn't know um from from Kelly is
just just watching kind of her process
it was it was kind of a this is this and
she could see her processing things but
she would she would try things out and
then do kind of like a process
elimination so she wasn't afraid to just
grab something and then no no that
wasn't good no that wasn't good so there
was it just a natural kind of filtering
process that she would do and then she
ultimately created these outfits and was
making five different outfits and then
in Antonio has it has a very logical in
step process and and so it feeds on both
sides of my brain which I liked and very
informative terms of just some of the
actual like technical things that again
that I like to know sometimes some of
the the whys just just because I process
things that way well also so show you
two different different ways but I tell
you I both work with me because I'm I'm
both sides of the cool so let me tell
you what I thought I was prepared
because mentally I'm thinking you know
here's real men real style he knows how
to get people to wear suits and Kelly
Nishimoto cute booties something more
with something new
I was expecting you to come out with
Kelly in a wedding dress that's what I
was expecting and I was expecting you to
come out in a full-on suit with with
Antonio and Antonio challenged me to
think bigger and more creative yesterday
at Saks which was a challenge and I'm
willing to work on that just so you know
that all right but I am very impressed
man both of you guys on what you've done
so can we get price points so five
hundred dollars a budget for each what
was your your budget at the end by the
time you guys were them but what did
this cost us well we did actually grab
in another pair of pants so that put us
at 497 but minus that extra pair of
pants we were just over 400 so so 400
with this outfit is $400 yeah and Kelly
how about how about your outfit we came
in at about 359 um which is kind of
funny because I'm usually an over budget
person so I was really surprising they
got to the register I think what really
kind of brought the price point down a
little bit was a good pair of Converse
that's always a great affordable shoe
that looks great for most everyone I'm
so that brought it down a little bit and
then the Calvin Klein shirt happened to
be on a super sale so that really
afforded us to get underwear undershirts
and a belt
we shall order lock and load them locked
and loves the idea that's that's the
idea our hopes right now now we're very
hopeful I personally appreciate you guys
being willing to take up the challenge
of doing the impossible because this is
a miracle for us to know that now Paul
is walking around thinking he's like a
combination it's not complete done it's
not done yet we got to close a deal and
so to close the deal to close the deal
here's what we need to do okay here's
what we need to do one we need you to
vote on the bottom here whether you're
watching us on the website Patra beta V
com or if you're watching this on
youtube comment on the bottom if you
like Antonio's outfit let's put the
picture up which is this one here on
what Paul looks like and if you like
Kelly's outfit that he got for Paul
which is right here you're looking at
the image of it if you're like Kelly
type in Kelly if you're like Antonio
type in Antonio and then now we'll see
which one is the better outfit and Paul
I kind of want to put you on the spot
light if you don't mind and this is my
first and rarely put you on the spot
light so this is my first time I'm doing
this I am I am willing to do this and
you got it you got to say yes or no if
you're opened if you're not open you got
to tell the public you're not open to it
I think it's a good idea if we give your
phone number out okay and if they want
to text you if anybody has any questions
or they can text you okay and we just
want to tell you not to do any kind of
sexting at this point let's first start
off with just a basic message if this
specimen here
six one six two two fifteen incredible
body fat great strong bone density he
talked about the possibility of great
family shoulders prominent chest Kelly
said incredible but size 12 and a half
shoes I mean I don't know where else to
go with this this is a if we were if we
were working on Kentucky Derby with
horses I mean you know you you want to
be able to sell the horse I can sell
this horse if you were astounded I'm
just saying it but we're not in that
business right
shucks I'm not a stallion I'm not an
agent I'm an insurance guy more value
taming guy entrepreneur guy so but we
want you to text Paul let me put the
number up here his number is Paul again
hang pink tied to one four six hundred
seven zero eight four two one four six
hundred seven or eight four I am so
curious to know about the response
you're gonna get we're going to judge a
lot of this success based on the amount
of context you're gonna get he's based
in Dallas Texas willing to get an uber
okay and I'm willing to get him to drive
either the Ferrari or the i8 to one of
the dates upon approval upon approval
you got autonomy and very clear he is a
man seeking a woman yes yes yeah that's
been clarified already thank you it was
doubt it at one point but it's been
clarified that bullying nothing wrong
with that but we're clear at this point
and so I mean I don't know what other
words are sullied you guys got any final
bus before we finished us off why I want
to compliment Antonio I love this jacket
I love that you chose that for him it's
something that can be dressed up and or
dress down I think that's a great piece
for a man to have in the class and Kelly
with your outfit I love that you
actually went with one of his favorite
colors purple and you're able to bring
that in make it look very strong and
masculine thank you you're what but just
on the behind scenes I had two old
separate him cuz it was a fight corner
this morning an absolute fight it was
screaming shouting we don't even need to
use that b-roll because it was terrible
things being thrown around all this
other stuff Kelly wanted to dye his hair
pink and there was there was a lot of
the stuff going on but only one copy out
there that was the issue
I won that battle but we gave you a copy
we gave you wine we gave you beer we
have the keg we have the 88 wine bottle
dispensed we gave you options last night
we had some extracurricular activities
so that we won't get into bring the
shirts we got some gifts were
we got some gifts for you here and we'll
take these pictures afterwards so Kelly
since you are miss ping okay we have an
I am an entrepreneur pink shirt for you
and body since you served the military
Marines we are appreciative of your
service
we got you a marine color I am an
entrepreneur shirt thank you for you to
sport thank you guys for taking time to
come out let's get that last pillow here
gang if you haven't subscribed to this
channel please do so you can subscribe
on the bottom again comment if you vote
for him and Tony on the bottom if you
vote Kelly Kelly on the bottom and you
can follow Antonio on real men real
style
on YouTube and I'm telling you we've
been following its content for quite
some time and it was purely accidental
when we followed you I think a year ago
or something like that and in about two
months ago or three months ago you
commented on one of the videos we had
though I've been stalking you even
started a channel first so start
stocking this mutual year so it's a
mutual stocking type of relationship and
then Kelly you know we got over the
stocking part eight years ago we became
friends and so here you can go to real
men real style on YouTube and all the
content are there with Kelly I suggest
you go to Kelly Nishimoto comm and from
there if you want to purchase her pants
that he didn't want to work as he
prefers Spanish but if you want to try
hit her pants I suggest you go to Kelly
Nishimoto and go to cute booty lounge
comm and purchase the pants you will
fall in love with them who knows maybe
we may even collaborate in the future
and do some other things and a lot of
you guys would love to hear you can't
see talk but style so what if we bring
you're not Antonio does something on a
monthly basis or something we do in the
future we don't know yet we'll talk
about figured out based on the response
we get with this and then Kelly for the
lady entrepreneurs she's got a lot of
things to talk about with
entrepreneurship for the woman maybe we
can do something there as well so with
that being said thank you so much
everybody for watching this episode
thank you gang for coming out Paul thank
you for your courage take care of your
bike